attention vers temps il arrive oui c'est
la fac nordique nordik impakt qui
commence ce soir au cargö
ça fait rire au parc des expositions
jusqu'à samedi soir on en reparle jeudi
à vendredi pour l'instant c'est mercredi
c'est donc cinéma avec la sortie d'un
excellent film qui s'appelle will
premier tournée dans la région
stéphanie lemaire jean michel guillot à
de ville d'abéché où marché là où ça
bouge aujourd'hui on vous parle cinéma
willy premier c'est une comédie
dramatique est particulière à plus d'un
titre puisque les jeunes il ya quatre
réalisateurs il a été tourné en
normandie
et par ailleurs il a été primé au
festival de deauville il a reçu le prix
d'ornano qui récompense le premier long
métrage français
oui avec ta mère tu vas pouvoir te
garder nos gabarits on atteint mètres un
centre spécialisé bull chez les bombers
55 ans willy et son frère jumeau vivent
encore chez leurs parents près de
caudebec-en-caux dans la campagne au
monde
son frère jumeau décède et à partir de
ce moment là il décide de partir de
prendre sa vie en main pour la première
fois pas sauvé vous dire quelque chose à
campbell j'irai avoir un appartement
avant lauréat a plus qu à leurs lauréats
découpage et en blu ray et vous en mer
ça c'est un truc qu'il a vraiment dit à
sa famille et dans cette phrase on s'est
dit bon ben là il ya la structure pour
faire un long métrage quoi est ce que
vous connaissez le principe du disque ou
non ce que
dans l'angle est oui alors on voulait
écrire un court métrage sur
l'illettrisme et du coup on faisait des
recherches sur ce thème
et là on a découvert un documentaire ou
france 2 suivent et daniel qui
apprenaient à lire à 50 ans avec une
association
on a fait ce qu'on a on s'inspirait
trajectoire et apprendre à romancer avec
aussi raconté devant un film de fiction
en l'idée ce n'est pas de faire un
documentaire
on était vraiment dans un désir de
vérité on n'avait pas forcément envie
d'enjoliver les choses donc on cherchait
plutôt le vrai qui avait justement dans
ces relations dans sa vie quotidienne
bah ouais je pense qu'après pénale moi
je crois qu'il tapait la boule ont l'art
qu'à un fake mongols ont essayé
d'utiliser le dispositif
cinématographique comme le ralenti la
musique pour faire de danielle tondreau
de woody un vrai héros de cinéma
pour apprendre les textes où ça s'était
produit l'an alors ils m'ont fait un
cahier avec des dessins et toujours et
c'est là que ça qui est des cinq voies
ferrées où il nous faisait déjà c'est
clairement salle à la fois bien écoutez
bien apprenez bien à lire à écrire parce
que c'est important quand tu sais pas
lire et écrire
on est on est un petit peu bête on est
appelé et moi ça m'a de développer un
appartement je leur ai rien
cook est rien
deco pas jaloux rue
vous emmerde le film c'est willy premier
et sert le 19 octobre dans les selles il
faut absolument aller le voir
voilà où ça bouge dans le vent et à
houlgate pour le 15ème festival du
cinéma européen et ça se passe là au
casino et au cinéma du casino
nous voilà dans le cinéma du casino
sylvain bonjour alors vous êtes
l'organisateur du festival cette année
c'est particulièrement ouvert aux
enfants ces nouveautés on peut dire oui
alors les il ya plus de vacances
scolaires pendant le festival dorénavant
on a gagné deux jours mais on n'a pas
changé les dates c'est l'éducation
nationale qui a travaillé pour nous donc
on propose des films gros pour le jeune
public aussi pour satisfaire les
vacanciers et notamment ma vie de qu'on
jette on propose un atelier de doublage
à la fin du film ça va être assez
intéressant
moi je sais pas j'ai pas ptc karaté
alors c'est aussi un festival du cinéma
européen alors est ce que dans ce cinéma
européen vous avez vu bien des perles
alors louise en hiver c'est frappant
parce que c'est dans une station
balnéaire du nord de la france en hiver
et ça me rappelle vraiment l'
architecture williate c'est assez
poétique
c'est à la fois beau poétique et
touchant
des films d'animation et des films tout
court le festival du cinéma européen ce
sont 27 films dont 16 avant première et
c'est tous les jours jusqu'au 25 octobre
ceci le mcg lorraine nous a déjà
transporté à jazz sous les pommiers
elle revient à coutances au théâtre
municipal cette fois vendredi